we got him. Ladies and gentlemen, Donald Trump's
tax records have finally been put in the hands of
the New York district attorney. You might remember
that late last week the Supreme Court made a
decision. Donald Trump can't keep shielding his
tax returns from the New York district attorney
and the grand jury that has been convened. Donald
Trump has fought for years and it has taken years
to make this a reality. Trump has fought for years
to keep his tax returns secret. Why has he done
it? We don't know. Presumably, Donald Trump
has made the calculation, maybe accurately,
that what is in the tax returns getting out is
far worse for him than the criticisms for keeping
the tax returns secret. In any case, prosecutors
now have the tax returns as of Monday. They got
them just hours after the Supreme Court said
no to the Trump final appeal for keeping those
records private. This includes millions of pages
of documents, according to sources, which include
Trump's tax returns going from January of 2011 to
August of twenty nineteen financial statements,
engagement agreements, documents relating
to the preparation of his tax returns,
work papers, communications related to the
tax returns. And this is a treasure trove
of information. Now, as a reminder, none of
this legally is to be released to the public.
The release of these tax returns and other
financial records are to New York prosecutors
for the purposes of investigation and use with
the grand jury that has been convened now,
is it possible that these documents will be
leaked? Of course. Of course. I don't I'm not
counting significantly on that, particularly when
it's widely known where they would have come from.
This is the only entity now that has had these
documents turned over to them. I think that
the risk would be high of deliberately leaking
them. Could they leak in some other way? Yeah,
maybe. Maybe at this point it's less about at this
point. I don't think even if they were to leak, no
matter what's in them, I don't think it would have
a significant impact. But there is still sort of
just a curiosity that I have, like what is in them
that is so bad that Donald Trump didn't want them
released. And we've speculated before one of the
revelations of Trump's tax returns could be one
that would simply affect Trump from the standpoint
of vanity, that the tax returns may reveal that
Donald Trump is not nearly as wealthy as he has
claimed to be. And that would be a reason for
Trump to want to keep them hidden more for vanity
than for any kind of legal repercussions. However,
it is conceivable that these tax returns would
reveal even more deception from Donald Trump
about the value of assets when it's advantageous
to inflate the value versus when it's advantageous
to downplay the value. And it could get Donald
Trump into financial trouble. It could expose
certain liabilities or other connections that
Donald Trump has, although much of that would
really be in a financial disclosure more than
in tax returns. So there's still a question
mark as to what exactly would be there, but we
simply won't know if and until we actually get
these documents released. So they are now
in the hands of New York prosecutors. Once
the Supreme Court ruled it happened very,
very quickly. And we will see ultimately
if we learn more about their contents, I'm not
holding my breath, but I would be fascinated